[Music]
okay
DJ Khaled might be
but he's not exactly the best at surfing
this is something that I really put my
everything into the rapper's been
documenting his trip to Turks and Caicos
on Instagram sharing moments from the
golf course
and the boat
okay so he didn't fall off the boat but
he did have an epic Wipeout when he
tried his hand at foil surfing
[Music]
yeah College started off strong but
totally ate it before he made it to
standing
man I want people to know
don't give up
you're saying even when you get
frustrated
you know what I'm saying don't complain
because it sets you back safe to say he
doesn't slay the waves
but he never misses in the studio
race in that love more love more
he chatted with the producer at the
Grammys earlier this year where he said
his family is his musical Muse I love
that you have the family yes it could
everywhere it's about family is what
family means this is the reason why I'm
here because this is my inspiration I'm
saying well I'm in the studio in life
you know obviously God has blessed us
but this is my inspiration God and my
family and my kids you know saying and
that's why this album God did is so in
was so important to us
um and it resonated with everybody over
the world and now we at the Grammys on
the red carpet talking to you Khaled
walked the carpet with his wife Nicole
tuck and their two sons Assad and Alam I
want to know what's it like at home
living with a force of nature a little
loud
it's fun and are you having a good time
with your dad tonight yes yes that's
right we the best yeah call it really is
the best
[Music]
but we gotta say we love to see his
playful side too